what i want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about polynomial end
behavior and this is really just talking
about what happens to a polynomial if as
as x becomes really large or really
really really negative for example we
know we're familiar with quadratic
polynomials where y is equal to a x
squared plus bx
plus c
we know that if a is greater than zero
this is going to be an upward opening
parabola of some kind so it's going to
look something like that the graph of
this of this equation or this function
you could say and if a is less than 0
if a is less than 0 it's going to be a
downward opening parabola it's going to
be a downward opening parabola
we spent less time with third degree
polynomials but we've also seen those a
little bit so for example if you have
the third degree polynomial
y
is equal to a x to the third plus b x
squared plus c x plus d
if a is greater than 0
if a
is i don't want to use that brown color
if a
if a is greater than 0 when x is really
really really negative this whole thing
is going to be really really really
negative
and then it's going to increase as x
becomes less negative less negative it's
going to do something that might do a
little bit of funky stuff in between but
then as x becomes more and more and more
positive it will become more and more
and more positive as well so it might
look it might look something like this
when a is greater than zero but what
about when a is less than zero well then
just like here we would flip it we would
flip it so that so let me write this so
if a is less than 0 if a is less than 0
when x is really negative you're going
to multiply that times a negative a and
you're going to get a positive value so
it's going to look something like this
and then it's going to go like this it
might do a little bit of this type of
business in between but then it's end
behavior it starts decreasing again it
starts decreasing so when we talk about
end behavior we're talking about the
idea of what is what is this function
what does this polynomial do is x
becomes really really really really
positive and as x becomes really really
really really negative and kind of you
know fully recognizing that some weird
things might be happening in the middle
but we just want to think about what
happens as extreme values of x now
obviously for a second degree polynomial
nothing really weird happens in the
middle but for a third degree polynomial
we see that some interesting things can
start can start happening in the middle
but the end behavior for third degree
polynomial
is that if a is greater than zero we're
starting really small really low values
and as a in becomes positive we get to
really high values if a is less than
zero we have the opposite and these are
kind of the two prototypes for
polynomials because from there we can
start thinking about any degree
polynomial so let's just think about the
situation let's just think about the
situation of a fourth degree polynomial
so let's say
y
is equal to a x to the fourth power plus
b x to the third plus c x squared plus d
x
plus i don't want to write e because e
has other meanings in mathematics i'll
say plus well i'm really running out of
letters here plus even f i don't want it
i'll just use f although this isn't the
function f this is just a constant f
right over here so let's just think
about what this might look like let's
think about its end behavior and we can
think about it relative to a second
degree polynomial
so its end behavior if x is really
really really really negative x to the
fourth is still going to be positive and
we're going to be if a is greater than
zero if a is greater than zero when x is
really really really negative we're
going to have really really positive
values
just like a second degree
and when x is really positive same thing
x to the fourth is going to be positive
times a is still going to be positive so
it's end behavior its end behavior is
going to look very similar to a second
degree polynomial now it might do it in
fact it probably will do some funky
stuff in between it might do something
that looks it might do something that
looks kind of kind of like that in
between but we care about the end
behavior so this is i guess you could
call the stuff that i've dotted line in
the middle this is called the non-end
behavior the middle behavior this will
be obviously be different than a second
degree polynomial but what happens at
the ends will be the same and the reason
why when you square something or you
raise something to the fourth power you
raise anything to any even power for
very large as long as a is greater than
zero for our very large positive values
you're going to get positive values and
for very large negative values you're
going to get very large positive values
you take a negative number raise it to
the 4th power or the second power you're
still going to get a positive value
likewise if a is less than 0 you're
going to have very similar end behavior
to this case for a a polynomial where
the highest degree where the highest
degree term
is even so this is a
is less than 0. your end behavior when a
is really really really really negative
this thing's going to be really really
really positive we're going to be
multiplying it times the negative so
it's going to be really really really
really negative
so it'll look like this and likewise
when x is x is really really really
positive you get the same thing because
you're going to be multiplying a
positive times a which is negative and
in between it might be doing something
it might do something
like that but it's end behavior you see
it's very similar to a second degree
polynomial
so if you ignore this
its end behavior is very similar now the
same is true for a fifth degree if you
were to compare it to a third degree
and the overall idea here is what
happens to what happens to this value
when we get really large x's or really
small x's
are we taking it to an even power in
which case for either really negative
values or really positive values we're
going to get positive values and then it
depends what our coefficient a is or are
we taking it to a odd are we taking it
to an odd power
so the general idea and actually let me
just do a fifth degree just to to make
the clear so if i had something of the
form y is equal to
a x to the fifth plus b x to the fourth
plus and it just went all the way i only
have to even write it this thing if a is
greater than zero
if a is greater than zero would look
something like this its end behavior is
very similar or it is similar to is
similar to a third degree polynomial
where a is greater than zero at the end
it would do this now it could it might
do it might do kind of some craziness
it might do some craziness like this
let me it might do something and i have
to get this right says one two three it
might do some craziness like this in
between but then for really large x's it
will look the same as x to as a x to the
third when a is greater than zero so
once again very very similar and
behavior when a is greater than zero and
very similar end behavior when a is less
than zero it would look like this at the
ends
at a negative value it will be positive
because this part is going to be really
negative but it's going to be multiplied
by negative to get a positive
and for really positive values of x it
will be negative because once again this
a term is going to be negative and then
what it does in between where at least
for the sake of this video we're not
really thinking about so the big
takeaway here and this is kind of a
little bit of a drum roll here when
we're talking about end behavior if
you're looking at an even degree
polynomial if you're looking at an even
degree polynomial it's going to have end
behavior like a second degree polynomial
if you ignore what happens in the middle
what happens at really negative values
of x and really positive values of x is
going to be very similar to a second
degree polynomial and if your degree is
odd you're going to have very similar
end behavior to a third degree
polynomial you might do all sorts of
craziness in the middle but given for
given a whether it's greater than zero
or less than zero you will have end
behavior like this or end behavior like
that